hey what's up everybody it's Warren and
a couple of days ago I did a video
talking about how there have been
reports that the spider-man far from
home trailer will be coming out on
January 15th which is Tuesday which is
tomorrow well since my report from a
couple of days ago there have been about
six other reports saying the same thing
that have come from very reliable
sources and now even Tom Holland himself
and Sony are teasing the trailer after
all these reports came out about the
spider-man far from home trailer coming
out on Tuesday one fan tweeted we want
the trailer for spider-man far from home
right now share this now well Tom
Holland actually retweeted this tweet
and commented on it saying I'll see what
I can do now there are a ton of tweets
every day asking about the spider-man
fire from home trailer and Tom Holland
has never applied to any of them so this
sort of seemed like a sign that the
trailer is going to come out on Tuesday
but just a couple of hours ago Tom
Holland tweeted so I spoke to Sony and
Sony even replied to him with a wave
obviously this is teasing that the
spider-man far from home trailer is
coming actors and studios have been
known to do this before in fact they did
it with Captain Marvel and according to
people from Sony's local partner in
China the first trailer for spider-man
far from home will be released in 24
hours and according to reports the
trailer will be released tomorrow at 9
a.m. Eastern Time 6 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time so be sure to be on the
lookout for the spider-man far from home
trailer tomorrow it seems like all of
the reports and even Tom Holland and
Sony point to it coming out tomorrow
Tuesday January 15th and once it comes
out be sure to check back here for a
full breakdown of the trailer so let me
know how excited you are to finally see
the spider-man far from home trailer in
the comments down below and I'm still
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]